the US ambassador to Russia has said two
huge aircraft carriers currently in the
Mediterranean are there to send a clear
signal to Moscow each of the carriers
operating in the Mediterranean at this
time represent 100,000 tons of
international diplomacy if Russia truly
seeks better relations with the United
States it must cease its destabilizing
activities around the world for more
we're joined live by Modena coach Nova
Modena what exactly has been said well
you just heard US ambassador to Russia
cooling the two US aircraft carriers
operating in the Mediterranean Sea a
diplomatic message to Russia the
Ambassador even visited a one of the
carrier say himself and called for
Moscow to stop its destabilizing
activities now for the first time since
2016 the United States is deploying two
aircraft carriers so close to Russia's
territory at the moment there are over
10 ships 130 aircrafts and over 9,000
Marines and sailors present in the area
two Carrier Strike groups operating
simultaneously while also integrating
and advancing interoperability with our
highly capable NATO allies and partners
provides an unprecedented deterrent
against unilateral aggression as well as
combined lethality Russia has already
reacted with the country's defense
minister cause saying that such actions
only lead to increased tensions and
demand certain response what was I need
I can assure you our response will be
taken in time and it won't necessarily
be a mirrored response well well show a
force appears to be erupting many will
be hoping it doesn't go any further than
that
Medina question about thank you for
bringing us that report
you